- Welcome back everybody.
I have one more story of holiday cheer.
Before we go, this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
But actually before we get to it
I have one last little Christmas
surprise for the audience.
This is an awesome tech item
that's perfect to give and get.
Jabra Elite 4 active true wireless sports
earbuds are waterproof and sweat proof.
Provide immersive sound with
active noise cancellation
and feature an ultra compact
and comfortable design.
Plus they're made to stay
in place while you work out.
That's annoying when they fall out.
I'm just saying.
Yeah, I see nods.
Yeah, these don't, that's awesome.
Anyone interested in
upping their earbud game?
(crowd cheering)
That works out.
Because you're all getting a set
of Jabra Elite 4 Active wireless earbuds.
(crowd cheering)
It is annoying when they fall out.
You don't wanna be working out
in the first place and they
fall out, it's annoying.
These won't, so you're lucky.
Moving on though.
As I said earlier, I've
missed a few days recently
I was a bit under the weather.
I feel much better.
But I am bummed that I missed
a story we recently did,
surprising the winning group
for the annual NBC 4 New
York Star Choir contest.
The winner got to perform at
the Rockefeller Tree Lighting
and this year's Star Choir
was P.S 14 in Queens.
Fortunately, Mario Lopez
and my musical director
Jason Halbert, stepped in
and handled it beautifully.
I'm also pleased to say that
P.S. 14 nailed their performance.
- ♪ Fa la la la la la la la la. ♪
♪ Troll the ancient yuletide carol ♪
♪ Fa la la la la la la la la. ♪
(crowd cheering)
- They're amazing, we love them.
We have choir directors Angelica Ortega
and Luanna Lasso on the line.
(crowd cheering)
It's nice to finally meet y'all.
Hello ladies.
- Hi Kelly.
- We're so excited.
- Oh my God, I'm excited over here.
So I hear the kids got
the red carpet treatment
is that right?
- Oh yes, they did.
We are so grateful and thank
you again for choosing us.
This was a win for the school,
but also a win for our community.
The outpour of support has
been just so heartwarming.
Our teachers, the day of the
tree lighting surprised us
and the children with a red
carpet exit with loved ones.
- [Kelly] Aww.
- Taking pictures and a luxury bus.
I mean, their reaction was priceless.
And all that love and encouragement
for their musical pursuits
has just done wonders
on their confidence and their self-esteem.
And then of course NBC
we're so appreciative.
So appreciative.
We received $5,000 so that we
can build our music program.
So we have big plans for that.
We're going to have rises for choir.
- Repairments for instruments,
new instruments for our students.
- And then staging and costumes
for our musical theater
production come this spring.
- And speaking of musical theater,
we cannot wait to see Wicked.
The children are so excited.
This will be their first
Broadway show ever.
I mean, it's gonna be memorable.
- It's gonna be so magical.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Thank you again for everything.
- Y'all do, so much for these kids
and making them feel so
special with that bus.
That's so cool.
And the red carpet thing, that's so cool.
Congratulations, the choir was
you know, very much deserving of winning.
I'm liking your post right now, right.
All right, and that's not all ladies.
Our season long partner
pilot pen makers of FriXion
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
want to see your choir continue to thrive.
So they're gonna give the
choir a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, thank you.
- Absolutely, thank you ladies.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Linda Cardellini, Poppy
Montgomery, Angie Thomas,
Nicola Yoon, Gabrielle
and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.